hey friends welcome back to the channel
i want to share a little clip from my
conversation with james hoffman if you
don't know james he's one of the world's
most famous and respected people in the
world of coffee he's got an enormous
following on social media he's got a
bestselling book and in this clip we're
trying to tackle the question of do you
really need to burn yourself out and to
hustle very hard to become successful by
society's traditional metrics anyway
let's roll the clip so the hero [ __ ]
of entrepreneurship of like i must grind
myself down
i'm a [ __ ] hero working super hard
i'm doing it right and it's such
[ __ ] and it's such a toxic aspect of
all work and i hate it but i definitely
worked 110 hour weeks for like months
ground myself down to the point of deep
misery and there is no
quicker way
to hate a thing you love
than to work like to work on it like
that right like i really love coffee i
definitely got to the point where i was
like i should quit coffee i should just
i i hate this i hate this i hate my life
i hate working in this i should just do
something else because i worked in a
stupid way and i burnt myself out
physically and emotionally because
people do that because the world says
good for you get the grind on you know i
mean what it's your thing it's yours
pull yourself into it you're like no
don't don't do that that's really bad
what you should do is start with enough
capital that you can hire people to work
with you pay them properly
and then work in a healthy manner do you
know what i mean like just have work and
home uh be separate that's helpful turn
off don't work at weekends or don't work
some days a week it's very satisfying
early doors to to pull yourself into a
business it is rewarding it's enjoyable
but
you're just burning through yourself so
fast and so i regret not starting with
probably twice as much money hiring more
people out of the gate and going home at
five o'clock do you know what i mean
like just be done just turn it off turn
off the go home enjoy life you can build
this thing you don't have to sacrifice
yourself for this
the downside is you need more money to
start with so that's that's the
trade-off
we didn't have that money we didn't know
we needed it we had enough to buy the
physical things not enough to build the
systems hire the people and so we just
worked ourselves to the bone and it was
miserable and i regret it and it was a
mistake oh
okay
on that point so
i feel like sort of uh at least in the
online
online discourse around starting
businesses circa 2013 to 2019
was the era of the hustle culture
movement saying that look you're
starting from nothing your 20s are for
hustling you've got to grind yourself to
the ground work on weekends work on
evenings to make that to start that
thing
since pandemic i think has accelerated
this there's a lot more like
that kind of approach of actually
sustainability is important etc etc
um but what a lot of the kind of
pro-hustle people say is that look
when
when you don't have that startup capital
like
and you're working your crappy job and
you need to start the business there is
not much you can do other than kind of
work between i don't know 7 p.m and 2
a.m and also work on weekends and all
that kind of stuff and i guess you're
just hoping it's just a season of time
so that you can build enough money build
a business off the ground because it
will take blood
theoretically it takes blood sweat and
tears to get a business off the ground
from from moment one
um
and a lot of entrepreneurs that i've
spoken to who have done that kind of
were grinding themselves to the ground
say that yeah it wasn't ideal it wasn't
really a happy time but without that
period of crunch which for several years
potentially the business wouldn't have
gotten off the ground so i guess my
question to you is do you think that you
would have been able to do it in a more
nice so sustainable way or do you think
it was necessary to put in the blood to
to get this get this off the ground i
think i think that the tricky bit is
that if i had had the understanding that
i have now
and a little bit more capital then yes
we could have built the same business
far more enjoyably i don't think it had
been a bigger business necessarily but
it would have been a more enjoyable
process to to do that and i think
certainly
you know i may start more businesses in
the future
and and i know that i got a little bit
hustly when youtube started to kick off
for me and it you know i mean i was like
oh i gotta feed this a little bit
because you know he feels when you when
it feels like you're pouring just
straight gas on flames and that's just
every everything you put in comes back
10 times you're like
quite addictive yeah but it then you
still end up with the well where are you
going with this like what's the yeah all
the big questions yeah yeah it doesn't
you might get to where you don't know
where you know you get to a point
slightly quicker but what's the point
you're trying to get to
do does it need to happen quicker is
that better
um so you look i i'm not saying that
there's a perfect way right like to to
back in 2008 to raise another hundred
grand
would have been really hard you know the
the the the the system that we live in
makes it much easier to raise one
million than 10 grand uh yeah
we can get a 10 grand bank overdraft but
i feel like if you go and pitch big and
you make big promises yeah you can raise
lots of money on the on the promise of
lots more later but if you want like a
10 grand overdraft please the bank's
like
no
yeah you're like i turn over like 30
grand a month and they're like uh-huh
and you're like 10 grand you know what i
mean like pre-financial crisis you could
get like a month's turnovers overdraft
was the sort of rule of thumb yeah and
post financial crisis the banks were
like nah uh which is really unhealthy
for for loads of small businesses it was
it really restricted access to capital
from 2008 probably to 2015 was really
difficult right
if you wanted less than 100 grand
the moment you wanted serious cash to
make big promises to to roll out this
giant thing that little ipo or there'll
be an exit much easier i mean for a
while i could easily raise it two
million quid yeah in a way that i
couldn't raise 200 grand that's what
that's messed up but that's that's the
way it was back then there still is now
reminds me of that quote which is that
um i think you you probably come across
it that um
uh if you owe the bank 200 000 it's your
problem if you owe the bank 200 million
it's their problem absolutely yeah yeah
absolutely
a weird weird system of capitalism but
that's what i mean like it's messed up
you know um
but yeah so you know i i'm perhaps
talking about this idealized world where
i could have found another 100 grand
somewhere in a way that that didn't you
know result in me signing over uh
control or or direction or or you know
what i mean some aspect that would be
later important but i do know that had
we accrued more capital at the start we
could have worked in a way that was less
damaging to our physical and mental
selves yeah and and you know i i think
you can justify culture all you like
i i just i i don't think i'm proud of
those years the way that i worked i mean
am i proud of where we got to yeah maybe
sure but i don't like that that was the
the root and i certainly wouldn't wish
that on anyone else and i would wish for
or encourage a a system or a way of
working that wasn't that
you know what i mean like i i would hope
for other people you know i don't feel
like i suffered you should suffer too
that's a sickness that affects our
culture i'm a i suffered i would like
you not to suffer because this sucked uh
that's sort of my feeling about life
so yeah i'm not saying there's a perfect
way it's a messed up system but that's
my experience and how i feel about it at
the end of it so i guess okay so let's
say if we if we could rewind 13 years
and you have the same understanding you
do now but you're in those market
conditions yes it sounds like you
probably would have spent more time
trying to figure out how do i actually
raise the startup capital i need such
that i don't burn myself out rather than
oh can't read a hundred grand
you know there's always other things we
could do if we knew the value of it but
i guess
at the time when you're at that stage of
life you're like oh i'll just i'll just
work harder
yeah that's absolutely it and certainly
the the the everything around me told me
that was the right thing to do
you know what i mean that was the the
culture around entrepreneurship was yeah
yeah you work you can put those out no
one else can do it for you to your
business
get out what you put in uh and i
believed it and but i i do i don't
you know i don't want someone watching
this to hear me say yeah you should
hustle yeah you should suffer
you know what i mean i i don't feel
comfortable saying those words to
someone hey friends thank you so much
for watching if you enjoyed this clip
then click here for the full unedited
episode and if you like that then do
please consider subscribing to the
channel it means a lot thank you so much
and have a great day